i've rewritten stokes's theorem right
over here what i want to focus on in
this video is the question of
orientation
because there are two different
orientations for our boundary curve we
could go in that direction like that or
we could go in the opposite direction we
could be going like that and there are
also two different orientations for this
normal vector the normal vector might
pop out like that or it could actually
go in to the surface like that so we
have to make sure that our orientations
are consistent and what i want to do is
give you two different ways of thinking
about it and you might think of others
but these are the ones that work for me
in order for stoke's theorem to hold we
have to make sure that we're not
actually picking the negative of one or
the other orientations and so the
easiest way for me to remember it is if
our normal vector if the normal vector
is let's say it goes in that direction
and if you have some hypothetical person
traversing the boundary of our surface
and their direction is pointed and their
head is pointed in the same direction as
the normal vector so this is the normal
vector so their head is pointed in the
exact same direction as the normal
vector so or you could say maybe their
body or really their head
so that's them then the direction that
you would have to actually traverse the
boundary is the direction that would
allow this person to keep the surface to
their left
so over here he would have to go in this
direction in order to keep the surface
to his left so he would have to go
he would have to go just like that if we
oriented the surface differently so let
me redraw the surface right over here
draw a similar surface so if we add a
surface so the surface looks very
similar
if this surface so this is a very
similar looking surface that i'm drawing
right over here just to give an idea of
some of the contours but if we said that
the normal vector for this surface we
oriented in the opposite way so if we
said that the normal vector here was
actually was actually pointing downward
like that then we would have to in order
for stoke's theorem to hold we would
have to traverse the boundary in a
different direction because once again
if i draw my little character right over
here his head is pointed in the
direction of the normal vector he is now
upside down so let me draw him so this
is him
this is him running right over here i
could draw a better job this is him
running right over here now in order to
keep and from his point of view this
would kind of look like a some type of a
pool or or a ditch of some kind it would
actually go down here it looks like a
hill to him but since he's upside down
in order for him to keep the boundary to
his left he would have to now go in he
would have to now go in the other
direction so depending on the
orientation of your normal vector or
which is really the orientation of your
of your actual surface will dictate how
you need to traverse the path now
another way to think about it and this
idea was introduced by one of the
viewers on youtube but it's a valid way
of thinking about it is to imagine that
the surface is the
is is a bottle cap and so let me draw
some type of a bottle over here
so i'll draw let me draw
a bottle
so this is you can imagine some type of
a glass soda bottle
so
but what we really care about is the cap
of the bottle so
make it make it feel like it's glass so
there that's our bottle
and let me draw
let me draw its cap
let me draw the cap of the bottle
because that's what we care about
we can kind of imagine that being the
surface so this is the cap
of our bottle and you just need to think
about well which way would i have to
twist the cap in order to make the cap
move up in order to take the cap off
and you could think of the normal
vectors the direction that the cap would
move
is the direction that the cap would move
and the twisting is the direction that
you would have to traverse the path so
you would have to twist the bottle that
way or you can think about the other way
if you twisted the bottle the other way
then the cap would move down so the
normal the normal vector is the
direction that the cap would move and
the direction that you would traverse
the the boundary is how you would
actually twist it so either of these are
ways of thinking about it but they're
important to keep in mind especially
once the shapes start getting a little
bit more convoluted and oriented in
strange ways